(inspiring piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brain.
Long the master of fire,
tools and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(electronic music)
So I'm going to extend some of the points
that Rusty raised,
but particularly in the
context of this structure,
which is the cerebral cortex.
So I think most people will be familiar,
this large folded
structure here at the top
is the cerebral cortex.
It makes up about three
quarters of the volume
of the human central nervous system.
And I think most people in this room
know functionally how important it is,
it's as I say here the
executive and integrative center
of the central nervous system.
It's a heap load of real estate,
it does important things
so it's affected by
a variety of diseases
that have their etiology
or their impact at
different stages in age,
starting from conditions
with a very early onset
in childhood, like autism,
right through to diseases of later life
like dementia or stroke
and those kind of things.
So what I'm gonna talk about today
is how do we start dealing with questions
about how do you control the development
of the cerebral cortex,
particularly in terms of size,
as a very simple concept.
And as I'm sure you've heard
in previous CARTA symposia,
and you'll hear this afternoon,
there's a lot of debate
about cognitive capacity,
cognitive ability, and its
anatomical underpinnings.
And is it bigger brains
make you smarter and so on?
But there's some degree of
agreement around the idea
that certainly more neurons
give you more processing power
at its most basic rate.
Complexity is probably
very important as well
in terms of elements that
one can build circuits from
and what you do with them.
But raw real estate is
also quite important.
And that becomes very obvious
when you start looking
at these three
cherry-picked primates here.
We've obviously got humans,
chimp and rhesus macaque.
And what we're looking at
here is the number of neurons
in each cerebral cortex.
Where you can see that human's has roughly
threefold as many compared to chimpanzee.
Even though in terms of
actual developmental time,
so I could ask this audience
how long do humans take
to develop, easy one for us
all to answer, nine months.
The chimp is roughly the same,
but you still end up with a brain
which has a cortex with about a third
of the number of neurons.
And then macaque, which is
shorter in development again,
but has tenfold fewer neurons.
So there's a very basic
developmental biology question,
is how do different organisms generate
different numbers of neurons
within their cerebral cortex?
And at what level is it controlled?
And by understanding
that question of control,
can we start thinking about
how you might then evolve
these differences between
different species,
and it plugs into the kind of genetics
and that kind of work that
you'll be hearing about
later in the afternoon.
So to think about this,
you've got to think about
developmental biology,
which is how do you actually make things
in the cortex in the first place.
And this is a picture from a mouse brain,
where this red thing,
this is a slice through the mouse brain,
this would be the outside,
this would be the inside.
And what all these little red blobs are,
these are what we would
call progenitor cells,
but for the sake of simplicity
I'll call them cortical stem cells.
So these guys aren't neurons,
this is before you have
any neurons in your brain
or in this case the mouse brain.
And this is a slice this
way through one half
of your cerebral cortex.
So the skin would be
out here, for example,
there's a hole in the
center of the brain here.
And these guys are lined up in a row.
And what happens is, these
cortical stem cells go on,
and this is them in black,
to generate cortical
neurons that are arranged
in layers over time.
So you do this inside-out development,
you make the deep layers before
you make the upper layers
and so on.
And this is a very stereotyped program
that plays out in every
single mouse in the same way.
And in a mouse it takes about six days
to generate all of these cells.
So that's fine, you've got one
big population of stem cells,
there's some very interesting
biology about them,
how they diversify.
But at its heart, these
guys make all of this
class of neurons.
So when you're thinking
about how you build a brain
you've got to think
about how they do this.
But a key concept within
this is what is the output
of each one of those cortical stem cells.
And there's a principle
in development here
where we talk about a clone.
No this isn't Dolly the sheep type clone,
this is a different clone,
just to make your life
slightly more complicated.
It's a very basic idea.
What it is is, in a mind experiment,
if you could label one of those red cells
in that previous slide,
with an indelible marker,
so every time it divides,
its daughter cells inherit
the indelible marker,
and let development play out over time.
What you'd end up doing is labeling
every single cell it made,
just passively by letting it roll.
So that's the idea, so you label a clone.
So if we're doing this in the cortex,
we know what the start to
cortical development looks like,
we've got these progenitor cells lined up.
We call this an epithelium, basically.
And we know what it looks like
at the end of development,
where you've got these layers of neurons,
and we've got little labels
that let us tell them apart.
The mind experiment,
and the real experiment,
is you then label one of these guys
with an indelible marker,
and let time play out.
And you do this, and you look at thousands
and thousands of these.
What you find is something very simple.
If you do this before
you make any neurons,
you end up with purple spots
that cross all the layers
and make all of the cells.
And what that tells you is you've got this
fundamental principle where
each cortical stem cell
will make a clone of cells that populates
all of the different neuronal types.
And so what that tells you
then is that your clone
is sort of an atomic unit of building
a structure within the nervous system.
This is true in the cortex
example I've given here.
It's actually true in your spinal cord,
your eye and so on.
And what that does is it gives you an idea
of thinking about this problem of,
at a kind of comparative
development level,
how do you make a bigger cortex in say
a human compared to a macaque, or a chimp?
And it's actually very simple.
So if you think about it in clonal terms,
either have more clones,
so increase the number of stem cells
before you ever even make the structure,
or actually change what
each stem cell does
in terms of what the
output of its clone is.
So make the production
from that clone larger.
And it's a way of ending
up with more neurons.
An example I've got up here,
this is mouse.
And mice are, for want of a better term,
relatively simple in this respect,
which is they have phases.
This is your starting stem
cell, it proliferates,
and then it has this linear program.
It expands itself, then
it starts making neurons,
during which it depletes itself.
Because you're eating up
stem cells to make neurons.
And then they switch to
make these supporting,
or these second cell type
in the nervous system,
the astrocyte, which is actually
functionally very important.
And it's a nice linear program.
So one of the big
questions in the field is
when you start getting to primates,
how complicated does this get?
Do you just take the simple template,
and just make more of them,
and you just generate
more real estate that way,
or do you diversify this and make it
much more complicated?
And how would this work?
And if you can understand
that then you can start
plugging in the molecular genetic stuff
and think well how does
this work within all this?
The question is how do you study this?
And labeling single cortical
stem cells in a human
might you get you in trouble
in most jurisdictions at this point.
(laughter)
So we did something similar
to what Rusty spoke about,
where in this case we were very much
focused on the cerebral cortex.
So we started with human,
and we took human embryonic stem cells,
or these induced pluripotent stem cells
that Rusty mentioned.
And what we essentially
worked out how to do,
using principles of developmental biology,
is make the cortical, just the cortical,
neural stem cell.
And they form these rather
pretty rosettes within this.
And what we found is
that we could put them
into the dish,
and they would replay this
generating the layers of neurons
on exactly the timescale that
they do in normal development,
but in utero, which was
a bit of a surprise.
And they actually go on and they make
these beautifully connected networks.
So these are neurons which
are firing away happily,
these human neurons.
So this was a bit of a surprise to us,
that they observed rules even though
they were isolated from the whole embryo.
So we then extended this
and said well what happens
if we look at these different species.
So this was worked on by Tomoki Otani
when he was in the lab.
And this was actually a
collaboration with Carol Marchetto
who you heard mentioned by Rusty,
and actually Eliza Curnow,
at the Primate Research
Institute up in Seattle.
And what essentially we did was work out
how to make pure cortex
from these cerebral cortexes
from these different species in the lab.
And this is John Gurdon down the bottom
for those of you who don't know.
Though we don't actually
have John's IPS cells.
We think there's a market
for them, (laughter),
a rather dodgy market
for them, but anyway.
So this is chimp, and there
are actually two different
species of macaque, because
we could get access to them.
So we could make the cortical stem cells,
and we could replay development.
And what we found was, each species,
just as it does in vivo,
has a developmental timescale
which it observes in the lab.
By which I mean, the green cells here,
so the bottom of each one of
these graphs here, is time,
and the green are those
deep layers of neurons,
and the red is these later-born neurons.
So every species makes green before red.
But what happens is the macaque makes red
much sooner than the
human does and the chimp.
And actually, the human and the chimp
look remarkably similar at the resolution
that we can look at with
these kind of assays.
So in fact, the rest of
what I'll talk about,
we just look at human and macaque.
Because actually human and
chimp look very similar.
Which is actually kind of reassuring,
because you'd want them
to look very similar,
given what you heard about in
terms of genome similarities.
So every species has a schedule,
and I should say the schedule
is remarkably similar
to what happens in utero.
And we extended this to
all sorts of other analyses
which I won't go into detail with here.
Including when do they make neurons,
when do they make different
classes of neurons,
and the kind of electrophysiology
you heard about,
when do they mature, when
do they form networks?
So what this provides us now is a platform
to start asking the mechanistic questions
that I mentioned, which is,
well how does the stem cell
that actually generates these
neurons within each species
behave in terms of making a cortex?
And what that involved doing,
is in the lab version of
the experiment I described,
where we label just one stem cell
in a population of tens of thousands
and actually watch that over time
and then look at lots of
individual stem cells.
And to do that we use a
trick where we take a virus
which is essentially we sort of damaged.
So this virus can infect a cell,
but it can never get back out again.
So it brings the marker with it,
the marker then stays.
So these are what we call
replication-incompetent lentiviruses.
This is a rosette made up of,
each one of these blobs is a stem cell
we label one stem cell.
And then we follow this thing dividing
over say 10 days in the lab
and we can reconstruct the clone.
And one of the challenges
here is as we mentioned
primate development is
very long and very slow.
So to give you some sort of benchmark,
mice will take over the world.
And the reason mice will
take over the world is
they do all their development
in less than 21 days.
And they generate litters
of, well you know,
those of you who have
been unfortunate enough
to have your garage overrun by mice.
As opposed to humans, and we
know how long humans take.
And I mentioned, the mice
will make the cortical neurons
at six days, humans will
do it over four or five,
six months.
And so you get an idea,
these clones become enormous.
So we have to look at
them in blocks of 10 days.
So the first 10 days,
second 10 days and so on.
And the first thing we
can do is start measuring,
what do they make and how do they make it?
And as biologists, we tend
to think biology's a mess.
You know, there are kind of
rules, but they're a bit dodgy,
and it's a bit tricky to make sense of it.
It's all about extracting
order from chaos.
And physicists think that
we're a bunch of Luddites
and that we can't think straight.
(laughter)
There are clearly
physicists in the audience,
I heard some sniggering.
And a colleague and friend
of mine at Cambridge,
who is a physicist, called Ben Simons,
says actually you biologists,
if you think of the complex datasets,
there's usually some
very important principles
underlying them.
And I said prove, and so he did.
And he took all this kind of data,
and he ripped them apart.
And rather than me
boring you for 10 minutes
with all the details, I'll
give you the punchline,
which is what I told him to tell me too.
Which is that essentially,
when we start looking at,
so for example this is,
how many stem cells are
within a clone, over time?
And this is, in the first 10
days, for example, 20 days.
Gray is the next 10 days and
black is the next 10 days.
And you see, actually in
each window of 10 days,
humans all look the same.
And what's happening over time is,
within the clone,
they're actually expanding
the number of stem cells
in the clone while making neurons.
So the the whole thing
is growing exponentially.
Macaques start off
looking very like humans,
and then they crash.
And what that really means is that
essentially the macaques
stop making neurons
much sooner than the humans do.
And it's a very simple thing.
What it means is that the humans make
these big long extended clones,
which allow them to make far more neurons
over a much longer period of time.
So they'll make more
neurons per stem cell.
And they do them in kind of clever ways,
stuff that I won't get into today.
Now, that's all fine, and
it's very descriptive.
It raises the second
question, which is well fine,
how does this work?
Now there's a very broad
distinction we like to make,
which is how much of this
biology is controlled
intrinsically, whatever that means
in terms of the mechanism.
And how much is controlled externally?
Signaling, environment.
You can boil it down
to the nature/nurture,
who do you know, what do you know.
But you get the basic principle.
I once heard that one
referred to the European
versus the American model,
but I couldn't work out
which one was meant to be
slightly not complimentary.
(laughter) But anyway.
So in this case what we can do is
we can essentially do transplantation.
Now clearly, I'm not gonna get a license
to transplant macaque cells
into humans, certainly,
and probably not the
other way round either.
But what we can do is,
we can do transplantation in the lab,
where we can label up,
say, the human stem cell
or the macaque stem
cell, and then move say
one in a thousand of those
into the other environment.
So essentially we're exposing them
to the other species'
environment and asking
now what will they do, at its simplest.
And we can then roll them out over time
and do all our maths.
And essentially, all I'm showing you here
is that nothing changes.
So I'll give you the punchline, which is,
the number of neurons a stem cell makes
is actually intrinsic to the species.
It's got nothing to do
with the environment,
at the resolution of this assay,
with all sorts of caveats around it
with what we're measuring.
By which we mean, if I
move macaque into human,
macaque doesn't care, it'll still make
what it wants to make
when it should make it.
And similarly with the human,
if I move human into macaque,
it'll still generate a
certain number of cells.
So that's quite striking,
but it's about numbers.
There's a second readout
which is very important,
which I've rather glossed over,
which is this what neurons do you make
and when do you make them?
So this idea of switching
from the early-born neurons
to the late-born neurons I mentioned.
And this was the thing I mentioned.
So we make layers, we mentioned this,
but also the humans here switch to making
these red guys much later than
the macaque do, for example.
And we can look at this as
well within these systems,
and again what we find is that,
if you look at these pie charts,
this pie chart looks
identical to this pie chart.
And what we're dong here
is putting human into human
or human into macaque, or vice versa,
macaque into human or
macaque into macaque.
And essentially, the species don't care.
They're going to do what
they're going to do.
They're sort of like my 11-year-old son,
in the sense that it doesn't
matter what environment,
there's a certain amount of pigheadedness.
So what this mean is,
and I don't know where they get it from,
I blame his mother. (laughter)
Anyway, so what we've learned
from these kind of studies
is that the primates do
development slightly differently.
And I should say something
which I haven't had time
to go into today, they
also do it differently
to small mammals like mice.
So this idea that early
on you're expanding
your stem cells while making neurons,
that's quite different
compared to small mammals.
So there's a big mammal problem
in addition to the primate problem.
And this is something which as a field
we haven't really grappled with yet.
There are such huge differences
between the kind of
tools we use in the lab
and the model organisms
we study in the lab,
like mice, in terms of
their biology, and primates.
That some of them aren't
to do with being primates,
they're to do with being large,
slowly-developing mammals
more than anything else.
But even within this difference,
what we find is that humans are different
to the smaller-brained primates.
And that essentially these
differences that I mentioned
are all cell-autonomous.
And what that then leaves us at,
and this is where we are now is,
this provides us with a platform
to ask what are these mechanisms?
How do we control what a stem cell does
and how it does it?
And our goal is, if we can identify
what those differences are,
what those cell-intrinsic controls are,
and clearly yes we all
think about genetics,
and there is an element of that,
but we have to be quite broad-minded
about what the cell-intrinsic clocks are.
Then looking at those
differences will give us insight
into evolutionary differences
by thinking backwards.
I should say there's
another side to this too,
which is the mechanisms that control
differences between species of brain size
are also very important
in two clinical contexts.
One is control of brain
size developmentally,
which has a very strong impact
on various intellectual disabilities,
and the other side is obviously
different kinds of brain cancer,
because it's the same
biology there as well.
So I'll just finish there,
and just to say I mentioned this was led
by Tomoki Otani, who was
in the lab up til recently
and is now with McKinsey in Tokyo,
and is carried on by two other people
within the lab that I've mentioned here.
And just to say that none of this work
would have been possible
without Ben, Rusty and Carol.
So thank you very much.
(applause)
Okay, the question that
we have been interested in
over the past 25 or so years,
is how do brains in evolution get bigger.
And to put the question into
a bit more specific terms,
what underlies the evolutionary increase
in the number of neurons
that are generated
in cortical development.
And as you heard from
the previous speakers,
this reflects the
activity of cortical stem
and progenitor cells,
and the answer how you get
more neurons formed is simple.
All you need is an increased and prolonged
proliferation of these
cortical stem cells.
The tricky question is,
what underlies the
differences across species?
Why do we have more neurons
than the macaque, or the chimp?
Let me give you a very brief introduction
to these stem cells.
What you see here is a
developing mouse brain.
And the neocortex, formed from a structure
called the dorsolateral telencephalon,
that is shown here in the box.
And shown here at greater magnification.
And what has fascinated
me as a cell biologist
over the years is that this cortical wall,
this developing cortical
wall, has polarity.
It has an apical side, as you
heard from previous speakers,
and a basal side.
And the process of making neurons
is a strict apical-to-basal process.
In which progenitors that form the primary
germinal layer, the ventricular zone,
progenitors that we collectively call
apical progenitors, but notably the apical
or ventricular radial glia,
these progenitors do
not make many neurons,
but rather generate a
secondary class of progenitors
that form the secondary layer
of the germinal zone called
the subventricular zone.
We call these collectively
basal progenitors
and there are two major types.
The basal, or outer, radial glia,
and basal intermediate progenitors.
In an important paper from
Collette Dehay and colleagues,
it was shown that in more
highly developed brains,
the outer subventricular
zone is very characteristic,
and it is very highly populated
by basal radial glial cells.
So these are the ones implicated
in cortical expansion.
There is actually a cell
biological reason why
these progenitors have
advantages to expand the cortex.
The apical progenitors,
because of their cell
biological nature, can
divide only at the ventricle.
And that's a very limited space.
In contrast, the basal
progenitors can divide
anywhere in the subventricular zone.
They can thicken the subventricular zone,
and this is a huge advantage
if one wants to maximize
the number of cell divisions.
This is the reason why
cortical expansion is linked
to basal progenitor
abundance and proliferation.
So a few years ago, we decided
then to embark on a search
for human-specific genes
that would do two things,
increase basal progenitor generation
and also induce or promote
basal progenitor proliferation.
And when I say we, I
talk about an outstanding
PhD student in the lab, Marta Florio.
What Marta has developed is
a cell biological approach
to isolate these two major
classes of stem cells.
This is a cartoon of the
developing cortical wall,
and you can label the
apical side with an antibody
against a protein called Prominin-1,
and the basal side with a
membrane dye that diffuses
into plasma membrane called DiI,
and with this approach,
you get a dual labeling
of the apical radial glia
and a single labeling
of the basal radial glia such
that the aRG's will be blue
and red, and the bRG's in
the mouse would only be red.
Now the neurons would also be red,
but in the mouse, you have
a transgenic mouse line
where the neurons are, in addition, green,
and we can sort them away.
So we get relatively pure populations.
In humans, this is more complicated,
and so we focused our attention
to those cells that had
duplicated the DNA, which
turns them into progenitors.
So the aRG's are blue plus red,
the bRG's are red only,
but please note that
the bRG's in the G one phase
end off the cell cycle,
so before they duplicate the DNA,
what we recovered in the
neuron fraction shown here,
and in fact, we know that
about 10% of the cells
in the neuron fraction are these cells.
This will become important
as you will see in a minute.
What Marta then did was she
isolated the cell populations
and determined the transcriptome and
went for those genes
that are highly expressed
in the stem cells and found a
total of about 400 such genes
that were highly expressed
in the basal and apical
radial glia, but very low in the neurons.
She then eliminated from
these roughly 400 genes
those which were also expressed
in the mouse stem cells,
which brought the number down to 266,
and then of these, she again
eliminated those that are
also expressed in the human
neurons or human cortical plate,
which brought the number down to 263.
These 263 genes come in two classes.
207 have an ortholog in the mouse genome,
but the gene is not expressed
in the mouse stem cells.
And 56 have no ortholog
in the mouse genome,
but exist, of course, in the human genome.
These were, for us, the
more interesting ones.
And now remember that we
noticed by the approach
of our way of isolating these
cells that 10% of the cells
in the neuron fraction would
actually be the stem cells,
the basal radial glia,
so we introduced another
filter and asked which of these 56 genes
is at least tenfold more highly expressed
in the stem cells than the neurons,
and amazingly, that reduced
the number down to one.
This one gene has this
pattern of expression.
It is highly expressed in the
apical and basal radial glia,
and this is the
contamination, if you wish,
of the bRG's in G one
in the neuron fraction.
This gene is called
ARHGAP11B, and as I said,
it is specifically expressed
in human, but not mouse,
apical and basal radial
glia, but not neurons.
This gene is interesting
for several reasons.
One is how it arose.
It arose as was first
shown by Evan Eichler,
who is actually here in the audience,
as a product of a partial
duplication of a ubiquitous gene
called ARHGAP11A, which
encodes a specific enzyme-like
protein called a Rho
GTPase activating protein.
But it has, in contrast
to the mother gene,
it does not have the GAP domain in full,
but it has a novel sequence
here at the C terminal end of
47 amino acids, which are
actually also specific to humans.
Now this sequence comes
about because 55 nucleotides,
shown here in purple,
which are present in 11A,
are actually not present in 11B,
and this leads to a reading frame shift
and this new green protein
sequence shown here.
And the other reason why
this gene is interesting is
when it arose in evolution.
As was shown by Evan Eichler,
but also by my friend
and colleague Svante Paabo,
who cannot be here today, unfortunately,
it arose about five million years ago,
after the lineage that
leads to the chimpanzee
segregated from the
lineage that leads to us,
but before the lineage that
leads to the neanderthals
segregated from the
lineage that leads to us,
and as you know, neanderthal brains
were at least as big as ours.
So we have here a gene that is expressed
in the right stem cell at the
right time of development,
and that is only found in those hominids
with one point three liter to
one point four liter brains.
So the obvious question
was, would that gene
increase brain size or
increase neuron number
in the model system, the mouse?
And this is what Marta investigated
by expressing the gene by a technique
that we call in utero electroporation,
and to make a long story
short, what she found was
that when you express
this human-specific gene
in the mouse developing
neocortex, it triples the
number of mitotically
active basal progenitors.
So the progenitor is implicated
in neocortex expansion.
So it increases these progenitors,
but there are two ways how it can do that.
Either you make more of these progenitors
from the apical radial
glia, or you increase
the proliferation of these
basal progenitors once formed.
And we solve this, or
we studied this issue
and made use of a method
that Elena Taverna developed.
Elena, like Marta, is also from Milan,
and you can believe me, these
are such outstanding people
that whenever I get an
application from Milan,
I accept it. (laughter)
So what Elena developed was a technique
where she microinjects
in organotypic slices
into the apical radial glia.
So here you'll see the slice,
and here you'll see the pipette,
and basically she injects blind,
but the pipette is filled
with fluorescent dextran,
and so you can identify the injected cell
and very accurately trace what happens
to the daughter cells
and granddaughter cells
of the cell after one cell
cycle or two cell cycles,
and what Elena could show,
and I'll just summarize
these data, is the following.
She showed that when you stick
in this human-specific gene,
you will change the mode
of division of the aRG cell
to a style where it immediately gives rise
to two basal progenitors.
That is good, but it's also bad
unless these basal progenitors
would keep on dividing,
and that is, in fact, the second
thing that ARHGAP11B does.
Normally in the mouse, one
of these basal progenitors
will make two neurons, but
in the presence of 11B,
it will now keep on proliferating.
So this is what we found in the mouse.
Nereo Kalebic very recently
expressed this human-specific
gene not in the mouse but in the ferret,
a carnivore with a folded brain.
And when he does that, he
found that also in the ferret,
11B massively increases
the basal progenitors,
but interestingly, it very
dramatically increases the
basal radial glia, which is
not what happened in the mouse.
But in the ferret, it
increases the relevant
basal progenitor type.
And importantly, these
basal radial glial cells
have markers that are very
characteristic of the human state
rather than the mouse
state or the ferret state.
So the other question we
ask is whether 11B can
induce folding of the mouse neocortex,
which normally is an unfolded brain.
So when we electroporate, we
have always a control side
which is smooth as shown here,
and then we can stick it in the gene,
and we see where it is
expressed by the green color,
and when we look five days after sticking
this human-specific gene into
a developing mouse brain,
we actually see that folds
can arise in about half
of the embryos that are
expressing this gene,
and here is another
case where you have the
electroporated area,
and you see these folds
in the mouse developing cortex,
which are somewhat
reminiscent of the folds
that happen in a fetal
human brain shown here.
Question is, how does 11B
achieve these effects?
Is it like the gene from which it arose,
11A, a RhoGAP question mark?
And so a post-doc fantastic
poster from Japan,
Takashi Namba took on that question,
made various constructs,
the mother gene, 11A,
a full GAP domain of 11A, a
truncated GAP domain of 11B,
and a modern 11B form,
and asked which of these
exhibits RhoGAP activity,
and the answer is
these upper two ones do,
and these bottom ones,
including 11B do not.
And we actually know
that the ability of 11B
to amplify basal progenitors
is tightly linked
to the existence of this new
green human-specific sequence.
Question then was can
the evolutionary increase
in brain size in us be
explained by ARHGAP11B?
And then we have a
problem because as I said,
even Eichler and Svante
showed that this gene
arose about five million years ago,
but at five million years
ago, our brains were small.
The big increase in
brain size happens later,
but we now have at least
an interesting possibility
of explaining this enigma.
And this has to do with
the question how this loss
of the 55 nucleotides that
gives rise to the reading
frame shift and the new
sequence actually comes about.
When we started this
work, we thought that as
the gene duplicated, these
55 nucleotides got lost
at the level of the genomic DNA,
but when we looked more closely,
we actually noticed that
the genomic DNA of 11B
contains these 55 nucleotides.
What's happening is something
much more interesting.
What you see here is on the
top, the sequence of 11A,
and this is the splice donor site,
the site where one
coding sequence is moved
and spliced onto the next one.
Now in 11B, there is a
point mutation, a C to a G,
which creates a new splice donor site,
and when this is taken,
the 55 nucleotides here
are removed, and that induces
the shift in the reading frame
because it truncates the
coding region of axon five,
and when that's spliced
together to a messenger RNA,
then you get a new protein sequence,
so this human-specific
sequence is caused by
a single nucleotide splice mutation.
This raised a very
interesting explanation,
or at least a possibility,
and that is that
ARHGAP11B arose with a full GAP domain
and having this activity
five million years ago,
and then later, but
before the neanderthals
branched off from our lineage,
later this point mutation takes place
which gives this protein a new function,
or this gene a new function.
So Marta investigated this possibility
by creating what we call
an ancestral ARHGAP11B.
So it is a gene that is
essentially the C DNA
that is essentially
identical to modern 11B,
except that it doesn't
have the G but the C.
So it cannot make the green sequence,
but makes this kind of a protein.
And we then ask the question
will this ancestral 11B
exhibit RhoGAP activity?
And so Takashi again
made various constructs
and tested the possible
activity in an assay
in which a decrease in phosphorylation is
indicative of RhoGAP activity.
And as you can see,
the modern 11B does not
exhibit RhoGAP activity,
but the ancestral 11B,
like the 11A, exhibits RhoGAP activity.
Next question then was would
this ARHGAP11B increase
basal progenitors and again
by in utero electroporation
into mice, in contrast to the modern 11B,
which increases basal progenitors,
the ancestral 11B is unable to do so.
So we have a rather interesting
situation as follows.
We have a single C to G base substitution
which creates a new
splice donor site in 11B.
That leads to the loss
of the 55 nucleotides
as the messenger RNA is made.
That causes a reading frame shift.
That leads to a human-specific
coax terminal sequence
that is key for basal progenitor
amplification, we believe.
So if ARHGAP11B should have
contributed to the increase
in the evolutionary increase
in brain size in humans
and neanderthals, it would have done so
by a single point mutation.
And with that, I would
just like to acknowledge
my collaborators Marta, who
is now a post-doc in Boston
with significant help from Mareike Albert,
Takashi Namba, and Elena
Taverna, and Nereo Kalebic,
who did the ferret work
that I briefly mentioned.
This is Dresden at night, and
these are people in my lab
I didn't have time to mention.
These are people who have left the lab.
This is the famous Semper Opera.
I am not over time yet, I noticed.
(laughter)
And we have the good
fortune of collaborating
with Svante Paabo, very
beautiful collaboration with him.
The fetal tissue was given
to us by Robert Lachmann
and Pauline Wimberger,
and we have a lot of pine
for medic support from Michael Hiller.
And these are present collaborators
outside of Glasten in Leipzig.
And this is the reconstructed
church in Glasten,
and I don't mention this
people's work on prominent,
but I would like to
acknowledge our support
by the Max Planck Society, the
German Research Foundation,
and the European Research Council,
and with that, I thank
you for your attention,
and I am curious which
questions you will write down.
(applause)
My job at the beginning at
least is a little simplified
because of the talks
you've heard from already,
especially from Rick and from Wieland.
As you all are well aware,
the human brain is the largest
among primates, living primates.
I just wanted to emphasize it's not
the largest mammal brain.
Elephants and whales and
cetaceans have larger,
and also more highly
folded cerebral cortices,
but in terms of brain number
in the cerebral cortex,
neuron number, humans have
the largest total number.
So my area of interest,
similar to Wieland's is,
one of the more obvious
features of the human brain
is its size and the number of cells,
and that brings us right to the issue of
where they all come from, which has been,
as you hear, a sort of interesting problem
or central problem for many of us.
The developmental stages
are clearly where we'll
find the answer to how that happens,
and in my lab, we've been
looking at human brain
development through the second trimester,
which is when most cortical
neurons are developed.
Cross section through the
developing cortex looks
very different in humans than it does,
for example in a mouse,
which is the animal system
that most neuroscientists
have used to study
early stages of brain development.
So this is the cross section of the mouse,
and you heard from
Wieland very beautifully
how there are apical progenitors
which we call radial glia,
shown here in red, marked by Sox2,
one of the transcription
factors that they express,
and their daughter cells are these
intermediate progenitors
that line up right above them
in this subventricular zone.
The beginning, the middle,
and the end of neurogenesis
in the mouse looks just like that.
In the human, it starts
out very similarly.
There are radial glial cells
and intermediate progenitors
forming these two layers,
but then very rapidly,
the subventricular zone
undergoes this enormous
expansion that you've heard about
and becomes an outer
subventricular zone shown here,
and all these colors represent
cells that are cycling.
They're producing daughter cells.
You may notice the
ventricular zone at this stage
becomes very small, and so the majority
of cortical neurons at these
stages almost certainly
are coming from this zone,
not from the ventricular zone.
And moreover, this isn't
the end of neurogenesis.
This is half-way through gestation week 17
when the middle layers are being formed.
So the middle and upper
cortical layers are
presumably being generated by the cells in
this outer subventricular zone.
But the actual nature of those progenitors
really haven't been studied,
and so we looked at it
in a variety of ways.
First I want to show you
how dynamic this area is.
In this case, we're looking at
the outer subventricular zone
in a slice culture where we've labeled
just the progenitor cells in green,
so there are neurons we don't see.
But the progenitors are highly dynamic.
When we look at them more carefully,
we find two classes, and
one that I really want
to emphasize is this one.
It's a radial glia-like cell.
It has a process that goes
up to the pia surface,
which is the basal fiber,
but it doesn't have an apical contact
with the ventricle the
way the epithelial cells
or the ventricular or
apical radial glia do.
Otherwise it looks just
like a radial glial cell.
It stains with all the markers
that you normally would see
in radial glial cells,
and if you back-fill
the surface of the cortex
with a label like this,
the DiI crystal, it fills
the fibers of these cells
that end in cell bodies in
the outer subventricular zone.
These cells hadn't been
described at the time,
so we call them outer subventricular
radial glia-like cells
or ORG cells, and as you heard,
Wieland calls them basal radial glia.
They're the same cell
type, and they're enriched,
it turns out, in the
human developing brain.
Now we've looked at them dynamically,
and were struck by a behavior
that hadn't been seen before.
These are four of the
cells that are labeled
in one slice of cortex,
and as they divide,
you may notice how they
sort of jump and divide,
and if you didn't notice
it in those images,
I hope you'll be able to
see it in this single cell.
Because as they go through M phase,
the actual cytokinesis
stage when they divide,
they jump first and then undergo this
cell division or cytokinesis.
Very distinctive behavior
that hadn't been described
before, and so we called it
mitotic somal translocation, MST
and it was one of the defining
features of these cells
because there were no specific
markers that we could use
to distinguish them from the traditional
ventricular radial glia.
But when we looked for
them in other species,
and this is in the mouse,
we found them there as well,
and if you watch the cell,
it's what we call now
a mouse outer radial glial cell,
and you see it goes through a little jump,
much more modest than the human cells.
It has this basal fiber, and it's located
in the subventricular
zone if the mouse had
a subventricular zone.
So these cells are present in
small numbers in the mouse,
and are usually expanded in primates,
and especially in humans.
Are they neurogenic?
Do they actually make neurons?
And to test that, we
actually dissociated cells
from the progenitor
zones, labeled them with
a virus marker that actually
just infected progenitors,
and then put a single progenitor
in each multi-well place,
and here's an example of a
single one of the progenitors
in this well, and a higher
magnification view is there.
Then we time-lapse imaged the behavior,
and you could identify
the outer radial glia
by their first division.
They put out a primary
process just like they would
in in situ, and then
they jumped and divided,
and that made that cell classified
as an outer radial glia.
We had other cells that
rounded up and divided.
Those were the intermediate progenitors,
and we looked seven weeks later in culture
at what the clones were like.
What does a single outer radial glia cell
actually produce, at least in vitro?
And the answer was really surprising.
The cells I showed you, after seven weeks,
have produced a clone
of at least 700 cells,
which included neurons of both
deeper and upper cortical layers.
And in this clone, there
were no astrocytes,
and some of the clones that
were additionally astrocytes
plus neurons, and this is
an enormous output of cells.
If we do the same experiment
with a radial glial cell
in a mouse, we get 20 to 40
cells after a month or so.
So 700 to 1000 cells from a
single outer radial glial cell,
I think underscores how
enormously proliferative
these cells are.
And so it helps support this model
which is still a work in progress
of what we think makes
human cortical development
distinct from say the mouse.
And in the ventricular and
subventricular zones shown here,
we think cells in human behave
very much like the mouse,
but what makes the human so distinct
is the outer subventricular zone,
which is filled with
these outer radial glia
which are born initially
from the ventricular zone
and move away, and they
go through these multiple
self-renewing asymmetrical divisions,
producing these daughters,
shown here in green,
which are transit
amplifying progenitor cells,
and they actually divide
symmetrically at least twice.
We know they do that more than once,
producing clones of cells which then have
the same birthdate and migrate, therefore,
to the same cortical layer.
And over time, one of these
ORG cells will produce
multiple clones of cells in
multiple different layers.
And the radial fibers
support neuronal migration.
So that allows an increase
in the cortical size
tangentially as well as radially.
So we think this cell is very important
for cortical expansion
both developmentally,
as shown here, and also
in evolutionary terms.
But as I said, we had no
markers for these cells.
We had no real idea of
what made them distinct
molecularly from the
ventricular radial glia
for example in the mouse.
So we took as an approach for this
is single cell RNA sequencing.
So we dissociated early cells, shown here,
took those individual
cells and collected them
in microliter tiny little
nano-sized capture sites
in a chip, a microfluidic chip
which is made by Fluidyne Corporation,
and when they're captured
in these little sites,
you can then do lysis
and reverse transcription
and amplify them and
then sequence the genes
for each individual cell.
And that's an unbiased way,
that is we take all comers
and see what those gene
differences look like.
Here is an example of a heed map
where we have the cells in all these rows
and genes in columns, and
you can see how they cluster
according to the genes that they express,
and that allows us to identify
molecular characteristics
of specific cell types.
And just to look at
some of the progenitors,
and this is when we first
did our initial study
of about 300 cells that
were captured this way,
we can see three different cell states.
Here in the lower left are
the radial glial genes,
the ones that are the most
enriched in radial glial cells.
In the brackets are the
intermediate progenitors,
which are the daughters
of the radial glia,
and then here on the
right on the upper side
are the enriched genes mostly
in young immature neurons.
What this shows us is that some genes
that are initially
expressed in the radial glia
persist in their daughter cells,
the intermediate progenitors,
and genes that are expressed
in those progenitors persist
as neurons are produced.
This is very useful in a
way because it helps us
watch the lineage of each of these cells.
So an example shown here actually confirms
what we saw from the time-lapse imaging.
Radial glial cells shown here on the left
producing intermediate progenitors
which then generate neurons,
and these are some of the genes
both known and new genes expressed
at each of these different stages.
We confirm the expression of the new genes
by in situ hybridization
shown here in slices.
Genes that we predict would
be expressed in radial glia
are located here at the ventricle.
Genes expressed in
intermediate progenitors
or radial glia are expressed here,
and then the neural genes are expressed
in the cortical plate.
Now not only did this give
us an idea of the transition
or lineage of cell types,
but it gave us insight into
activated gene networks that
might actually be signaling
individual cell types, and to focus on the
outer radial glia for this talk.
These are all schematically shown genes
that are coherent in networks
expressed exclusively
by outer radial glia at
these developmental stages,
and one of those gene
networks and pathways
is the LIFR STAT3 signaling pathway
known to most stem cell biologists
as an important self-renewal pathway.
So we find that these
outer radial glia cells
are actually able to self-renew themselves
and create their own niche.
If we inhibit this pathway,
as shown here on these graphs
on the lower right, we
significantly inhibit
the generation of the radial glial cells,
but not the intermediate progenitors,
or for that matter, the
ventricular radial glia.
So it's selective to this one cell type.
And it helps support an idea shown here
that distinguishes the
human from the mouse.
In the mouse, as you
know, as we just heard,
they have radial glial cells
and intermediate progenitors
and the radial glial
cells line the ventricle
where they can receive
trophic factor signaling
from the CSF, cerebrospinal fluid.
In the outer subventricular
zone, the cells
have actually moved
away from the ventricle,
and they're not able to
access the growth factors
in the CSF, but instead,
they develop their own
signaling pathways.
They can produce their own growth factors,
and they create their own niche
for self-renewal and expansion.
We think that that is one
of the reasons, of course,
that these cells were able to undergo
the kind of prolonged
and massive proliferation
that I've shown you and that
Wieland mentioned earlier.
We've also gotten some
insights into diseases,
and I just want to mention
two of them very quickly.
One of them is this.
And as I've just mentioned,
these outer radial glial cells
make their own niche, and
they have factors that
promote self-renewal, and when
we looked at all these genes
in the literature, we
found that they'd all been
reported earlier or already discovered
in this particular kind of tumor,
the glioblastoma multiforme,
which is a terrible
and inoperable brain
tumor found in adults,
not in children.
But when we look
carefully at the published
single cell heed maps, like this one,
for radial glial genes,
rather for genes that are
expressed in tumors as
well as radial glia,
we cross those reference points,
we found that in fact, the
most aggressive glioblastomas
were enriched in the
same genes that we found
in the outer radial glial cells.
They had apparently an
outer radial glial signature
in the most aggressive
grade of glioblastoma.
So then we looked in surgical specimens
that we got from our colleagues at UCSF,
sectioned and stained, and cultured them
just like we had primary tissue,
and shown here are glioblastoma cells
from one of the patients.
And focus your attention on this cell
as it undergoes division.
I hope you can see it.
Yeah, there it is.
Watch that one.
Here we go.
Right, so you may have
noticed how it jumped
and divided exactly like
the fetal cells do in situ.
So it looks as if we have
outer radial glial cells
in these glioblastomas
and in fact, that work has
progressed to the point where
we now have good evidence
that these may be the cells of origin for
these very aggressive glioblastoma tumors.
The next slide, which has
to do with microcephaly,
and microcephaly, of
course, is a condition
where the brain is orders
of magnitude smaller
than it would normally be.
The most dramatic cases
of this occurred in Brazil
last summer when there was an outbreak
of Zika-induced microcephaly,
but initially it wasn't
clear that the Zika virus
was producing the microcephaly.
We were struck by the fact that literature
suggested there was one specific factor
that mediated the entry of
the Zika virus into the skin,
and that was something
called the AXL receptor.
And our data set from
the outer radial glia
that we've been talking
about and the other cells
in the developing brain
shown here for all of the
receptors known to mediate
entry of flaviviruses.
And the Zika virus uses
the ones shown here
with the black dots to
get into other cell types.
And I'll emphasize that the AXL receptor,
which mediates Zika
entry into other cells is
highly enriched, but only in
certain cells in our data set.
Shown here it's enriched in astrocytes,
in radial glial cells, not
intermediate progenitors,
not in neurons, not in interneurons,
and also in microglia and endothelium.
It has a very specific
pattern of expression,
which we predicted might be the
tropism of the virus as well.
That is, the virus would
enter the cells that
express that receptor.
So we managed some
collaboration with Joe Darigia
to get active virus from
a patient who traveled
to San Francisco from Brazil,
and he was donating blood,
and the blood actually turned
out to have active virus.
So we cultured the virus and
exposed our tissue sections.
Shown here in green is the Zika virus
reproducing in cells in the
outer subventricular zone,
which included the
outer radial glial cells
that I've been talking about.
It seems to be that they're a
very favorite target of the Zika virus.
So shown here, in fact, is
the outer radial glial cell
packed with the viral particles
just prior to rupture.
So those outer subventricular
zone cells are specifically
and especially vulnerable to
infection with the Zika virus.
When these patients are
born with microcephaly,
it makes sense, of course, that
the neural progenitor cells
might be selectively affected,
and there's much more that goes on
in this devastating
condition than just infection
of these outer radial glia, but this seems
to be a part of the picture.
And we also took advantage of the fact
that AXL, we hypothesized, was
mediating entry of the virus
to block it with a variety
of different chemicals
and antibodies and
shown here is an example
of a chemical block of the AXL receptor,
and these are cultured human cells
that are exposed to the virus,
and green dots are the cells
that are actually infected
with the virus, and if you
block the AXL receptors,
shown here on the right,
you can significantly reduce
the cells that get infected.
Confirming that the AXL
receptors are probably mediating
entry into at least
these human cell types.
Now I was very interested,
as I mentioned earlier,
to find markers or
genes uniquely expressed
in these outer radial glia
that we could use as a tool
to try to learn more about the cell types.
Now we're very gratified
in our first 300 cells
that we were able to do that.
Shown on the left are novel markers
that express themselves only in the
ventricular radial glia, shown here,
and on the right are the
more interesting, to me,
novel gene markers that are expressed in
outer radial glia only.
And we justified or rather,
we've validated these markers
first by showing that they stain cells
with the morphology and
location of outer radial glia,
but also dynamically, we
watch cells in our time-lapse
imaging jump and divide,
and then we fix them
and stain them with
these markers to confirm
that the cells that were jumping
were in fact expressing these
outer radial glial markers,
and they were.
So this gives us, now,
a whole new set of tools
to start looking at these
outer radial glial cells.
One of the first things we noticed,
challenges, or I should say
modifies this classic model
of human cortical, or
primate cortical development
that Pasko Rakic proposed known as
the Radial Unit Hypothesis.
Very influential and
still very very concise
explanation of how radial units form
and how they multiply over
time and also evolution.
And I want to emphasize the
radial glial scaffold here,
which are all these fibers
go from radial glia down here
to the cortex along which neurons migrate.
And the model proposed that this scaffold
persists throughout cortical development.
And we were struck,
when we had new markers,
as I mentioned just a moment
ago, that there seems to be a
discontinuation of the radial
glial fibers at later stages.
And that was evident from
these two cell markers.
In red, I'm showing you HOPX,
which is a gene expressed
throughout the outer radial
glial cell cytoplasm,
and you can see red
fibers that you can trace
all the way up to the pia surface.
In green is CRYAB, which
is a marker our data
suggested was only in
ventricular radial glia,
and the green fibers only went up to the
outer subventricular zone
and never went further
at these later stages,
suggesting that these
fibers and these fibers
were discontinuous, and we
checked that in a different way
by using DiI, which is a lipophilic dye
that can be transported
along radial fibers.
And if we put those crystals on the top
or the bottom of this slice, either way,
we were able to show
these continuous fibers
at ages up to around gestational week 16.
But beyond that, the
picture was quite different.
If we put DiI at the
surface, it backfilled fibers
only to the outer subventricular zone
where they end in outer
radial glial cells,
and if we put the DiI at the ventricle,
it only went generally as far as the same
outer subventricular
zone, suggesting a kind of
a hand-off of cells from
one zone to the other.
And that led to this
model which is a model
that suggests that the
second half of neurogenesis,
the upper cortical layers are produced
by outer radial glia, not by
these ventricular radial glia,
which now have transformed
into truncated radial glia.
So we think there are
three kinds of radial glia
in human cortical development.
And we've now expanded
our single cell analysis
to all these different cell types.
It's given us an idea
not only of the diversity
of cell types that are
produced in the human brain
compared to the mouse,
but we've also identified
unique markers for each of
these different cell types
at different stages of development,
in different brain regions,
and one of them I want
to mention is DAB1 which
is a reelin affector.
It's found in radial glia at the ventricle
and the outer radial glia, but not in the
truncated radial glia,
which would be here.
And what's interesting
is that these two cells
have fibers that go all
the way up to the pia
where they can receive reelin signaling,
and the tRG's don't.
So it very nicely justifies or validates
the discontinuous glial scaffold model
that I showed you earlier.
And then I just wanted
to summarize the points
that I've made so far,
that the development or
evolution of these three
neural stem cell types,
the ventricular, outer,
and truncated radial glia,
we think help understand
the expansion and organization
of cerebral cortex.
That these outer radial
glial cells are enriched
in self-renewal and proliferation genes,
and that has led to some
disease associated effects,
and that the mechanism
for human developmental
and evolutionary brain
expansion could be co-opted
in disorders like brain tumors,
and could be targeted in
disorders such as microcephaly.
And finally, I want to
thank all the people
that did all the work,
especially Aparna, Alex, and Tom,
very gifted post-docs.
Alex and Tom are setting up
their own labs now at UCSF,
and our sponsoring organizations.
Thank you for your attention.
(applause)
(chime music)